Larry P Arnn is the 12th president of
Hillsdale College he received his BA
from Arkansas State University and his
MA and PhD in government from the
Claremont Graduate School he served as
director of her search for Sir Martin
Gilbert the official biographer of
Winston Churchill from 1985 to 2000 he
served as president of the Claremont
Institute for the Study of statesmanship
and political philosophy in 1996 he was
the founding chairman of the California
Civil Rights initiative or proposition
209 this was passed by California voters
and it prohibited racial preferences and
state hiring contracting and admissions
he is on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the Henry Salvatori
center of Claremont McKenna College and
the Claremont Institute he served on the
US Army War College Board of Visitors
for two years for which he earned the
Department of the Army's outstanding
civilian Service Medal he is a member of
the American Political Science
Association the Mont peril Pelerin
society the International Churchill
society and the philanthropy roundtable
published widely in national newspapers
magazines and periodicals on issues of
Public Policy history and political
theory he is the author of Liberty and
learning the evolution of American
education and the founders key the
divine and natural connection between
the Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it he is
currently writing a book on
statesmanship and the constitutionalism
of Sir Winston Churchill dr. Arnn
is a professor of politics and history
at Hillsdale he teaches courses on
Aristotle Winston Churchill and on the
American Constitution he and his wife
Penelope have four children Henry Katie
Alice and Tony please join me in
welcoming dr. Larry our
thank you Jim Holloman and the chamber
course I leaned over to the provost I
have a device of whispering the Provost
during ceremonies because he's a
tremendous man and we're friends and I
said you know it's a big day and here we
did it again we put the first team on
the field thank you David
I'll tell you story about him he leaned
over and whispered to me that he had a
moment of panic when Matthew introduced
the subject of the end of a horse you
didn't seem all that smart sometimes
does he Thank You Morgan
I just noticed and I can't help but
comment that Morgan's mother sits right
there and of course Dugan the next one
to come and after that maverick and
after that Winston are coming they're
all sitting there Cleaves is not here I
don't know what that's about but the
thing that's worth noting is Isaac the
worthless undergraduate who dates Morgan
is sitting by Morgan's mother and that
must mean that boys getting really
ambitious stand up Isaac so they can see
yeah you've seen Morgan and you've seen
Isaac you can't you join me in saying no
way that's gonna work out and I
apologize for Matthew and for the
college if he gets his four-point this
year he'll be the sixth person in 21
years to do it but forget about the end
of the horse I have on more than one
occasion heard him in the last 12 months
abusing the personal pronoun with the
wrong case she's what what see but he
can't get a boy if he does that actually
Morgan and Matthew are tremendous people
and it's a privilege to work with them
and I bet there's a lot just like them
sitting out there among our new class
with the parents of the members of the
class of 2018 stand up so we can see you
please thank you I give you the warmest
welcome I have a hard thing to say and a
happy thing to say to you the hard thing
is that I'm almost done now and now when
I'm done and we're gonna dismiss and
your kids gonna walk up there and join a
bunch of people and you're not gonna see
them anymore
before that happens you're going to
stand up and make a pledge that's going
to be sentimental it is very and if you
watch and I urge you not to you're gonna
see that your kid is very happy and when
he comes home or she the first time
they're likely to slip and mention that
in certain number of days they're about
to go back home and that will strike at
the heart and my wife and I have four
children and I join you in that misery
but of course here I'm on the good end
of the transaction
but there's compensation for that
because you're here and here is a very
unusual place in a way I'm going to
explain to your children in just a
minute and one of the things about it is
we do ask you to make a commitment
during this ceremony and that's because
we need and we welcome your help
one of the advantages of not taking any
money from the federal government is
that we are liberated to talk to you
about your child I urge you to come to
parents weekend you'll get to meet the
people who teach your child if there's
trouble and we think you need to know
we'll call you if you call us we will
answer your questions the main work is
to be done with your child between him
or her and us and you have to remember
that and you have to do your part one of
the key things is if we have a dispute
with your child which is very unlikely
you have to take our side you can find
out later for right and if we're wrong
we'll correct it but the first thing to
say well you're an idiot to the kid and
we're going to make that work I promise
it's our relations with the parents are
joyful I like to say in my work I've
become an excellent judge of kid flesh
and an excellent judge of parent flesh
I'm used to the mothers who interrupt
when you're teasing their child and
asking them questions they can't answer
and then I'm used to the only other kind
there is and that's the ones that twitch
but don't quite do that and I want you
to know you're very welcome here and
we're so glad to have you now there are
two things you freshmen need to know and
they're dispositive of the case things
are the way they are here for reasons
that are written in our natures and we
can't get rid of them they really are
two that you should know the first is
the word college means partnership
nobody thinks of it that way anymore
it's a scene of diversity and difference
and self-expression but the word
literally means partnership and that's
because of something in the middle of us
something about us Matthew
you know despite his poor grammar and
his his metaphor about the horse was
either inartful or very artful and if it
was artful then he's a lot of your boy
that I know him to be but his talk as
was Morgan's was brilliant he's okay you
know he's pretty smart and he works hard
and what he says is your kind of thing
and that kind of thing makes you able to
talk and talking is just the verbal
tangible expression of a thing that's
proceeding in your soul because we can
talk we can think in a way that we think
we can oh man and God and horse and boy
and child and parent and because we can
know those things that's also why we can
talk and so this is the thing that is
made for us to do together and you will
find that it's just a fact especially by
the time you get to be seniors I ask you
to begin to reflect on this now when you
watch how things work you will find that
your friends as Morgan said and as
Matthew said and you know by the way no
grown-up had a hand in the writing of
what they had to say no read it in
advance
except of course all the grown-ups
sitting right there they all did
welcome back faculty and welcomed the 10
new members of the faculty and what they
know is they have benefitted massively
from the work and the help and the
reasoning of everybody here especially
fellow students because they clarify
things together and they live together
and they eat together that's what a
college is and the first thing you have
to know is the reason we've asked you to
sign this on our coat is because this is
just a fact and to the extent that this
fact is not realized in actual practice
to that extent the college is diminished
and that means nobody here is ever going
to say to the expression you are only
hurting yourself
welcome to the partnership
the second thing is the human soul works
this way knowledge to us is not really a
position we can keep unless we sustain
the activity of it so a long time ago I
studied Greek I wasn't a genius like the
people in our classroom classics but I
got a long ways and then I stopped for
30 40 years now and I just regret that
so much because I don't know it I can
read words but what do they mean I can
parse a few out right wouldn't it be
great to know that it's one of my
ambitions if I ever retire which I might
not I probably just fall over I'd like
to study Greek and you know they can
teach it down there those guys and I've
extracted promises from a little that
they will teach it to me and you know
get a chance to get back at me some huh
but that what does that mean for you
what that means is you have to commit to
live a certain way beginning now and not
ending that means cramming to get an A
is not the heart of the matter you can
do that if you want to you won't get it
anyway but the heart of the matter is to
raise yourself to a being that knows
what it is and what it is for and can
compare itself to the beast below and
God above and give meaning to those
conceptions and so the point is
everything here is organized to produce
that effect among everyone here and
that's hard and we're we don't fancy
that's hard because we set high
standards we don't think we have any
power to set the standards we think the
standards just turned out to be high and
it's our business to meet them and we're
you to help you do that but you must
help because the main work is yours so
good
boots on there's a lot to do use it also
it's joyful joyful for me in particular
and I'll tell you why
the thing about 18 year olds and 21 year
olds to some of the charm comes off by
the time they're seniors but they've got
to this place in life where they can do
anything that we grown-ups can do they
just never have done it before and so
they don't have any experience
whatsoever and so like their pranks are
often incredibly foolish but also so
often are they're serious attempts and
that's because they're learning how and
you think we don't laugh about that
around here and they laugh with each
other all the time I mean Morgan just
told about two near-death experiences
and if she thinks they're kind of funny
now you know because death doesn't mean
they hurt anything to her it's so
distant and you know more than that joy
of watching the young and the foolish
become older and less foolish that's
very joyful and you will feel the
strength within you grow that's the real
thing though isn't it because when you
see a thing that you have long to
understand and add that to the other
things you learn step by step by step
you become truly and fully human truly
and fully good
understand the weight of the fact that
what you're about to undertake is not
typical
we have 2700 competitors and these
freshmen are all smart enough to get
into all but maybe 30 or 40 of them and
most of the freshmen smart enough to get
into them too and so you've come here I
know for the weather but it's a very
different experience here we're going to
read a bunch of old books and we're
going to read a bunch of new books and
we're going to read the natural sciences
and we're going to discover that those
books don't agree with one another and
we're going to have the patience and the
energy to try to understand each one as
it was written and tried to reach an
understanding of our own of the things
that are good and the things that are
true and above all the things that are
beautiful which my colleague professor
Jackson tells me the other night smoking
cigars I can confess it that he has
redefined the term beautiful as the
difficult and he means that because
you're too young to know beauty yet you
just have to look at it as difficult
later it will be beautiful and the
knowing of those things was regarded for
2,500 years as the ultimate fulfillment
of college and that is largely discarded
I don't exaggerate in colleges today and
you know what's funny
that is behind the changes in our
government which the college has always
had an interest in that building up
there the old one was dedicated on the
4th of July in 1853 because we thought
those laws of nature and of nature's God
meant something what they thought we
thought they meant in particular but you
couldn't put a collar around the neck of
a man you could around the neck of a
horse so you Matthew that's how you talk
about the front part of the horse
and so the college is known in every
corner of the land and you have come
from every corner of the land and it is
known for that thing and yet we swim in
the academic sea and your students have
gone to high schools that are likely
affected by those doctrines without
knowing that there are alternatives and
our students will leave and go to
professional school and graduate school
and those places are dominated by those
doctrines in the main and so there's a
pressure here all the time a pressure of
difference and that's good for us also
taxing upon us we feel the weight of it
all the time and you will to and yet we
count that then and remember this point
in let let me another bind to our
friendship the fact that we carry this
on in defiance and without circumventing
the arguments but taking all of them
seriously we think that that is a vital
service to the world to the country to
all of our fellow citizens
why on earth somebody try to make an
ugly car sound like a harley-davidson
which is not an ugly thing if we're to
do that and if it's true that we're to
do that together for the sake of your
child first to you parents for the sake
of your fellow students and yourself and
the college for the sake of it for you
to you freshmen and to all of us in the
college community for the purposes for
which the college was founded then my
last point is very simple we're going to
have to be friends we're going to have
to learn about each other and we're
gonna have to love each other and on
behalf of the college I promised that to
you with a heartfelt welcome